the bureau it sounds like a TV series or  a desk in fact it's a team of people  within the European Parliament the  Bureau is made up of the parliament  presidents his or her 14th vice  presidents and cui stirs the bureau  makes important financial organizational  and administrative decisions on matters  concerning Emmie peas and the  parliaments internal organization if the  president represents the parliaments  both within the EU and externally and  signs the budget and new EU laws vice  president's lead working groups of MEP s  and represent condiment on key policy  issues and they chair plenary debates  when the president is not in the chamber  Krishna is a Roman word meaning an  official in charge of public finances  today in the European Parliament the cui  stirs advise and represent MEP s on  financial and administrative matters  under parliamentary procedures  [Music]